- Very warm welcome, everybody.
Hopefully this isn't your last session
of the day after a very long day.
It was an amazing keynote this morning,
and I hope today will set
the scene for that too,
for all of those incredible
things that are coming
as we evolve and adapt our
journey through Agentic AI.
And I think, if there was ever a time
to be in technology, it's now,
and I'm sure you're all as excited as me
to be not only here at re:Invent,
but also in this profession.
It's an amazing privilege.
Anyway, I'm going to talk to you about
the data transformation journey at NatWest
that Nina just signposted.
I'm gonna talk a little bit
about the technology, of course,
'cause I know that's what
you're interested in.
But I'll set the scene at first,
just with a little bit more
around who we are as a bank
and what we're trying to achieve,
because I do think, you know,
all of us as technologists,
we seek out really challenging problems
with amazing people to work with
and where those problems have mission
and purpose that connect
with us personally.
At least that's what I do.
And I'm sure that's the case for you too.
And I joined NatWest because
of those three things
coming together, you know,
the opportunity to bring
world-class technology to work
with incredible people,
with incredible partnerships
with Accenture and AWS on a mission
and purpose that actually
really matters for people.
And in the UK and in Europe
where financial services is
disrupting hugely right now,
where the competition is really hot,
but where people want to be
able to trust their bank,
they want to be able to be
treated as a human being
at their time of greatest need, perhaps,
when they're most vulnerable
or at the time of greatest joy
when they perhaps are
buying their first house
and no doubt every other
interaction in between.
But for those interactions
to feel personal,
and I know that's what I want.
So the opportunity to bring cloud,
to bring mobile, to bring digital,
to bring AI, to bring Agentic,
to bring excellent
engineering practices into
what is a really big transformation
is a super interesting
problem to be part of,
but also a privilege.
So, a little bit about me.
So I joined NatWest just last year,
having spent three and a
half years in healthcare,
on a similar mission, all cloud-native,
modernizing core data
and digital backbones.
And prior to that, 10 years at BP,
where equally huge global organization
wrestling with its own
modernization journey,
its own transformation,
its own reinvention to renewables
and again, bringing scaled
enterprise technology
to that problem has been really what I do.
And it's great to then to be able to bring
that experience now to NatWest.
So, NatWest, one of the most respected
and well-known brands in the UK,
purple, my favorite color, actually.
20 million customers and
a huge committed staff.
So 60,000-plus employees,
half of whom are engineers and technology
and half of whom are
supporting our customers
and many of those in frontline roles.
So, you're a very big community
of people supporting
those customers every day.
And as part of that journey,
as part of that core infrastructure,
supporting upwards of half
of the UK's payments
transactions every day.
It's a very complex technical landscape
and real ambitious plan to modernize
that traditional banking platform
and banking architecture into something
that is really genuinely
fit for an Agentic future,
a modern digital, customer-centric future.
And the bank is all
about bringing customer,
bringing that hyper-personalization of one
to everything that we do
and using modern cloud-native
technologies to do it.
Really, I loved, I don't
whether you did too,
I loved the Sony presentation this morning
that talked about experiences
that make you feel different.
And just imagine if
your banking experience
felt different too.
And I do genuinely think that it matters.
It matters how your bank treats you
and how your money is managed
and whether you trust the people
that are looking after it.
So that's what we're
trying to do at scale.
But it doesn't start in a way that's easy.
So, not only are we a 300-year-old bank,
sometimes it feels like we
have 300-year-old technology,
a 50-year-old mainframe,
200 million lines of COBOL,
very fragmented landscape
that has been diversified
through acquisition.
We have the main retail bank,
which you all know and love, NatWest.
We have a private bank, a wealth bank,
Coutts, banker to the royal family,
many of the wealthy inhabitants of the UK,
and then a very strong and well respected
commercial institutional bank.
But guess what, we don't actually know
which of those customers are
using products from Coutts
or NatWest or the commercial
bank or the business bank.
And that's the journey that we've started
that, recognizing the huge ambition
to become a hyper-personalized,
customer-centric digital bank starts
with knowing your customers.
And that's the heritage
to this transformation that we're on
and establishing a world-class
data spine for NatWest
that will enable that
hyper-personalization,
that will enable that growth,
will enable those intimate experiences,
but delivered in a way that
is simple, is standardized,
is automated, and is cloud-native.
And that's the journey.
So when we think about
becoming a simpler bank,
we think about simplicity
in terms of how that simplicity
shows up to customers.
So it's not just about
switching off technology,
it's not just about turning off apps.
It's not just about
removing that horrible COBOL
that we've all lived with for so long.
It's not about that at all.
It's about simplifying the journeys
and the experiences of our customers
and doing that in a way
that is sustainable,
that is frictionless, that is modern,
and that creates those
experiences that we want.
And we're starting from a place that
perhaps no one would
really want to, actually,
where we have today nearly 30
customer master databases across the bank.
And our ambition is to
reduce that significantly
to three or less,
where we have very slow delivery,
particularly in our data environments,
but also in our core banking environments
where we're looking to often weeks,
if not months to release
and an ambition to compete
with the near banks
of not only hundreds of
releases a day, but thousands.
And that's our ambition.
And then of course, as any bank,
a very demanding regulatory environment
that requires really strong governance,
not just of our interactions
with our customers,
but of course with our data.
And our ambition is to
really simplify all of that
in a way that enables those
customer-centric interactions.
And when we looked at this journey,
we realized that two things,
one, we didn't have the capability really
both on the engineering side
and on the product side to deliver it,
but secondly, it was gonna take too long.
And that's where we looked
to our partnerships,
that's where we looked to Accenture
and we looked to AWS as
our technology partner
to enable that agility, that pace,
but most critically,
bringing forward the timeline to delivery.
And when you're in transformation
of this kind of scale,
I know many of you all know
from your own companies
that partners really matter.
And how you select your
partners really matter.
Are they aligned with your ambitions?
Do they connect with you personally?
Do you have that alignment on mission?
But more importantly, is there mutuality?
Is there capability that
will be brought to you
by that partner that will create
a one plus one equals three multiplier.
And we were incredibly
fortunate to have two
of those partners here today,
AWS and Accenture, who are
creating that multiplier effect
for this transformation journey.
And we're really delighted with
the progress that we've made
so far, and the journey continues.
And of course, it's not
without bumps in the road.
Transformations of this scale never are.
But a lesson in selecting
partners to be aligned
to your mission and purpose,
to be bringing something
that you don't have
and to creating that
real cohesion of outcome
is really what's driving
the success of this program.
So establishing the data spine of NatWest.
So, we've done a huge amount of work
to define our target architecture,
our target reference
architecture for the bank.
I'm super happy to talk about that
in more detail in the break or afterwards.
Please do reach out to me.
A big part of that, the
modernization of NatWest,
comes through its data.
And how we think about those outcomes,
again, is not about the technology,
it's about what those
outcomes are for customers.
And within our institutional
bank, for example,
it can take up to 17 weeks
to onboard a business banking customer.
I mean, that's a
ridiculous amount of time.
Why is that?
Because the processes are fragmented.
It's because there's a
lot of paperwork still.
There's a lot of to'ing and fro'ing,
'cause we don't know our customers.
We don't know that perhaps they're already
a retail customer.
They might already be a
business banking customer.
And we're not able therefore
to accelerate that journey
or avoid repeating and
asking the same questions.
In the retail bank,
retail banks win and lose on the pace
and the agility and
delivery of new products
and the delivery of products
which are really personalized
to you as an individual.
I don't know about you,
I get deeply irritated when
you get emails or messages
or WhatsApp messages from organizations
who clearly don't know you,
because they're trying
to sell you something
you obviously don't need.
And banks can be the same.
But our ambition is to
know our customers so well
that our interactions with
them are hyper-personalized
to those individuals.
And that's our retail banking ambition.
In the finance space,
we have enormously
complex finance landscape,
both from a regulatory
reporting point of view,
but equally because of the variety
and disparate nature of
the financial transactions
across all of our banking platforms.
And the finance aspect of
the finance simplification
is a big part of this
data transformation too.
But arguably actually
one of the most complex.
We have 30,000 Informatica batch jobs
that run every night, for example.
Most of which are posting
adjustments to transactions
that are making, aggregating apples
and pears to create oranges.
And this simplification journey
from a finance point of view is all about
just creating that seamless,
frictionless transaction to general ledger
to P&L in a world-class way.
And then financial crime.
And one of the things that probably most
of us worry about every day
with our money is, is it safe?
And even for me actually
yesterday arriving,
trying to pay for the
hotel with my credit card,
the fraud detection jumped in.
Well, if the bank had actually
known that I was traveling
and they should have done,
then that would've been a
more seamless experience.
And that's what we're trying
to achieve with NatWest,
that we know our customers,
we know where they're going,
we understand their transactions
and we're able to keep them safe every day
through world-class AI,
through world-class detection response
and prevention of
financial crime and fraud.
So an enormous vision, enormous ambition,
all of which, of course,
starts with the data.
If we're to be the nation's
most customer-centric
and digital bank, then we
need to know our customers.
And this data transformation is anchored
on that very premise.
So let's talk a little bit
about the technology then,
which I'm sure you're all waiting for.
So we started in a world
of a very traditional
on-prem Teradata, Snowflake architecture,
a traditional data warehouse
and emerging analytics capability,
but a very traditional
monolithic architecture.
And we are moving to, through
this transformation journey
and we're well on the way, thanks to many
of the great products from AWS,
we're moving to a modern
data mesh architecture,
but with a twist,
and I'll tell you a little bit
about that twist in a minute.
Traditional data mesh architecture,
which has the four characteristics.
So, distributed data ownership,
so establishing data
owners in the businesses
and real governance and
control of that data.
Secondly, data as product.
So establishing foundational
data products across the bank
that are reusable and consumable.
Third is self-service infrastructure.
So where we started was
in a world that said,
if you want to know about your data,
then you get a report
in a spreadsheet that
ask someone, you raise
a ticket in service now
and then it comes back to you in a week.
This is about turning that
180 degrees to a self-service,
data-driven architecture.
So that's the third
characteristic of the data mesh.
And then fourthly, distributed
and automated governance.
And I'd argue, in reality,
that's the hardest bit of this journey.
So, that architecture that we're building
is anchored on replacing Teradata
over time, diminishing and
reducing the Snowflake footprint
into AWS Lakehouse
with glue and lake
formation for governance,
and then a fantastic mesh architecture
through what we know within
the banker's data marketplace,
but it gives you that access
to federated data products.
And then, where the twist is
and where the magic comes, of course,
is how you then make those
data products enabled
and accessible through a semantic layer
through natural language for consumption.
But then critically,
how you have that foundational platform
to enable agents and Agentic AI.
And that's where we're really excited
with the partnership with AWS.
We're really excited with the
partnership with Accenture,
who brought some of
those agents to the table
with us already to enable that,
not just the scale build,
but the scale consumption
and the automated augmented
consumption of data
to everybody in the bank.
When I started at NatWest,
there was very little concept
of a data-driven culture.
Some of this may resonate
with you, I'm sure.
And I would be in an EXCO
and I would perhaps ask a question,
"So how many customers do we have?"
And the head of retail would say,
"Well, I think we have about
19 and a half million."
Well, where we're moving to
now is we've banned the term
"I think" in favor of,
"I know because the data
tells me," or "I don't know,
but I'll look to the data to find out."
And that shift from subjective thinking
that you might know the answer,
to real trusted data assets
delivered through a modern data spine,
accessed through a semantic
natural language consumption
and then automated through and with agents
could not be a more different world.
And we've achieved much of that already
in an 18-month period.
And the partnership with
Accenture enabled WS is all
about scale, but it is
critically all about pace,
and we expect to have been
very well along that journey
by the end of 2027, and
that's our ambition.
And this isn't for the faint-hearted.
You can imagine a world
of a 300-year-old bank,
5,500 applications,
very little discoverability
of those applications
and a mindset that is very traditional
anchored on traditional
management information
accessed through spreadsheets.
So this journey isn't
just about the technology,
of course, it's about the ways of working,
which I think is also super interesting
how you can use these emblematic programs
such as this data of transformation
to not just enable that
outcome for our customers,
not just simplify and modernize the bank,
but also use it as the
focal point to simplify
and modernize the practices as well.
And I think that's where you
really get the multiplier
effect of working with partners
such as Accenture and AWS.
Oh, I pressed the button twice.
It might go on twice.
So a little bit more about
the architecture then.
You probably can't see this terribly well,
but I know the slides
are available afterwards.
So as I said, what do you see here?
You see a classic mesh architecture
that is then coexisting with a modern
cloud-native Lakehouse architecture
and a series of transition
architectures that allow us
to decommission the
Teradata, diminish Snowflake,
bring in self-service, bring
in the Agentic AI layer.
And these are three boxes you see.
So, in the middle of the
slide there at the bottom,
that's the data marketplace.
That's the mesh,
that's the engine room
of our transformation.
And then slightly to the left
of that is the governance.
And then just above that is the Lakehouse
and the cloud-native data lake
for the management information
and the MI reporting, et cetera.
So yeah, I mean, pretty
standard probably for some
of you more advanced
practitioners out there.
But where this is interesting
for us as technologists
is where you're doing two
things, one, coexisting.
The target architecture is
never the hard bit, is it?
It's the transition to it,
to managing that coexistence.
And then secondly,
recognizing that actually some
of these products are still very immature.
So we've been working very closely
with AWS on the development
of SageMaker Unified Studio,
which, of course, is the platform
for our data marketplace.
And then increasingly
with the product teams
with Bedrock and now, of course, AgentCore
for creating our Agentic architecture
that is consuming these data products.
Incredibly exciting.
We would never even been having
that conversation had we
not got this fabric right
and then enabling it to scale.
And working with the product
team at AWS is a privilege.
Of course, you've got some
outstanding technologists there,
but the openness to
adapt to our requirements
has been a really, really strong feature
of this partnership actually.
And so if you're sat
there, you're wondering
about some features
that perhaps are missing
or wondering how you get
those into the backlog,
just to engage with those product teams.
I think you get a really,
really strong response
and teams of people who are
desperately keen to work
with you and anchor their
own product features
off your own needs.
So that's our architecture.
But of course, it's not
just about the technology.
I wish it was.
It's about so many other things.
And when you're scaling and transforming
a 300-year-old bank, there's a number
of things you really need to get right.
And choosing the technology probably
is one of the easiest things.
What's been most important for us, then,
is real clarity on mission and purpose.
You recall I said at the
beginning, I certainly am
personally motivated by complex problems
that can be solved with
modern technologies,
working with incredible people
on a mission and purpose that matters.
But getting that clarity
for all 60,000 employees
and the broader communities
from across our partnerships
is really important.
And we've been incredibly
lucky and work very hard
actually across all three
of our organizations
to get executive-level
sponsorship for this program.
And I can't underestimate
the importance of that,
you know, particularly
when things get a bit bumpy
at times, don't they?
Of course they do.
They're meant to, progress
isn't meant to be easy,
but having that executive-level,
CEO-level sponsorship
of this program with
real clarity of purpose
where there's obvious
value for the customers
that we serve across our nation
is the most important thing,
and alignment on that
across the three partners.
And a few others too.
I mean, you probably also wrestle
with this annual funding debacle.
Hopefully you don't,
maybe you've all moved to product models
and continuous funding.
We haven't, sadly, not fully anyway.
So you're really setting out
an ambition that is multi-year
and then committing to the funding
and sticking with it.
You have to do that.
I think that this relentless
hair cutting of budgets
every year just causes these
kind of programs to fail.
So we've committed to the
duration of this program
and we've committed to
the funding upfront.
And then, of course, having the ability
and the adaptability to
course correct though.
So I think in reality
what we set out to build,
even at the start of this year,
is different to what we're now building,
because what's happened?
Well, the world of AI's come, hasn't it?
Agentic AI wasn't even in our vocabulary
probably six months ago, let alone three.
So, thinking about how we
course correct this architecture
to really scale AI and agents
has been an important part
of the adaptation, which has been possible
through having the foundations
and having those foundations built.
And then finally, I
probably would call out
sticking to an industrialized method.
And I think that's also
where partnerships come in.
How are you gonna deliver
this and stick to it?
How are you gonna mobilize
your whole organization,
have a standardized pattern of delivery
that is industrial scale
that allows you to go faster?
So, establishing that factory mindset
and factory model has
been really critical.
We're not fully there yet,
but we're getting there.
But I would absolutely say
that if you're embarking on a program
of this kind of scale,
working through really
precisely your delivery model
and approach, codifying
that, automating that
so that you can go as
fast as you possibly can
is really important.
So, what have we learned along the way?
We've learned a huge amount actually.
And I'd love to hear any
questions you may have
that I've not covered yet,
but across three areas really.
And this is towards the
end of what I'm gonna say
and then we'll open up for questions.
So, I've covered this
already on the context side.
So, it is fair to say,
and I'm sure you all know,
AWS SageMaker Unified
Studio is a new product.
It's been evolving over
the last 12 months.
So, working with AWS
directly on developing
that product so it's fit for purpose
and not just has the
features and functions,
but also has the industrial
strength that's required
of a platform of this scale.
That has been a journey,
but we've worked really hard on it
and been super successful, I'd say.
Of course, collaborating
with the product teams,
I've talked about that already.
I think, in terms of opportunity,
this federated model.
So, with the data mesh,
I'm sure many of you have
built data mesh architectures.
One of the huge benefits is
autonomy of the consumers
of the mesh.
But also your ability
to federate ownership
and accountability to where the
data is created and managed.
And that's been a really,
really high-impact journey
and high-impact outcome for us at NatWest.
Some more to go,
but empowering people to take
responsibility for their data
is such an incredible part
of any data transformation.
And then where the challenges be.
The biggest challenge really
is clarity on operating model.
I would say it's the technology, it's not.
It's not the technology at all.
We've got amazing technologists,
incredible technology.
We've got amazing partners.
It's about mobilizing those
towards a magnetic north
that we're all bought into.
But actually the hard bit comes
when you're not clear
on whose job is what,
and getting the operating
model of the delivery
and the operating model of
the consuming businesses,
super important to do that up front.
And I think, probably for me,
that's one the strong lessons learned
is not to leave that to the end,
is to establish that
operating model early.
So you've got people bought in,
they're learning the technology,
they're learning the vocabulary,
they're learning the ways of working
that enables these platforms
to be really successful.
And guess what, now once you've done that,
you can then scale the
automation through Agentic,
and the magic really does
happen then for customers.
And with that, I'll pause and
open the floor for questions.